hello everybody hope that you are good
this video is a bit different it's a bit
special because after 9 months of work I
can officially say that we have a own
indicator ready it's finished well at
least the first version cuz if you
notice the name of the indicator is v.1
first version and that's because there
are a few things to change to polish and
for that we're going to need to do more
versions because the ultimate goal is
the indicator goes live goes public for
everybody in trading View and for that
it needs to be perfect so yes we're want
to go through different versions
changing a a few things to make it
perfect okay so yes we're already
working in the second version because
there are a couple of visual books that
we have to fix but overall the indicator
is here to make uh charting easier and I
say charting and not trading because I
think trading is something more complex
trading involves also control of
emotions risk management ER experience
but charting I mean in the way that for
example I don't have to draw the trading
sessions manually those boxes you know
that and I'm not going to miss any week
any liquidity pull so yes it's here to
make your lives a bit easier now let's
talk about the indicator the indicator
um it marks the weeks the liquidity
pools the trading sessions and the FMA
which is multi-time frame so you have
basically four indicators into one and
we've put it into only one indicator
because I know that many of if you have
the free version of of trading view
which is normal CU it's perfectly fine
and you I think you can only access two
indicators so well with this indicator
you have a few so that's what we P
everything into one but the good thing
is that you can remove things so for
example you could remove the we fill
strategy or the liquidity pools imagine
that you only want to see the liquidity
pools and well then you can remove the w
f strategy um you can also remove the
50ma okay so um I like that you can
activate things on and off more things
well for the liquidity pools we have two
formulas and this indicator has been
very difficult to to make and it took so
long because it's new no what this
didn't exist before there is not one
indicator in Trad view that marks the
weeks there is not one indicator in TR
view that marks liquidity pools yes they
Mark fair value gaps and other stuff but
not liquidity pools that it's only the a
large candle
body and for that we have to put two
formulas of liquidity pools okay we have
this one here and another one there so I
recommend you to activate both of them
that's the first thing um these are by
the way the uh settings that are by
default I didn't change anything so
you're going to have this this same
settings now the 50a something
interesting that I like is I have the
multitime frame setting that means that
that right now we're in the 4our time
frame but we can for example set the
50ma in the daily time frame you can see
how it changes there you saw that so now
the we have the daily 15a in or 4our
time frame okay let me put it back to
how it was if you set chart then the 50a
shows in the same time frame as you are
okay now we updates I like also that
it's quite fast it doesn't take long to
update things and of course you have
here the trading sessions now for the
trading sessions you have to go maximum
one hour time frame so you can be in the
15 minutes time frame well 5 minutes
time frame 15 minutes time frame 30
minutes time frame and 1 hour time frame
you cannot use this in a higher time
frame okay because if not it gets booked
but it's normal you this if not these
sessions take two candles it wouldn't
make sense okay so for example you can
go to the one hour time
frame let's go there
okay and you can see that INX the week
we have a week to the downside it marks
the 50% and the 100% of the week we have
another one up there it marks the
liquidity pools and if you notice yes
because we have two formulas then
sometimes this happens and is that this
is a visual book that we're currently
working on and it's because the two
formulas identify the same liquidity
pool but if you notice is that if you
remove one of the
formulas then you show that you've lost
two liquidity pools You've Lost That one
there and also that one there okay so
let's put it back there and sometimes
maybe this is not the case but sometimes
if you remove this
formula let's see not in this case but
in other cases then you miss liquidity
pool so basically this first check here
of liquidity pool is the main formula
and this second one is uh let's say
complimentary I don't know how to say it
but it basically complement or helps the
first Formula to to not miss any okay so
I recommend you leaving both of them
activated although you have the visual
book there that again in the second
version it'll be uh completely fixed
that's one of that's basically the main
thing that we're working on to remove
that visual book there that is a bit
annoying okay now how can you use this
indicator well H hang on let me show you
the the trading sessions so for the
trading sessions I've already put by
default my my time my time frames and
the guys of the course uh know more
about this about how to use the trading
sessions but basically I know that
London last later until even 5 p.m. but
I P it I finish at two because that's
when New York starts so I think that New
York takes all the protagonism so I
think London finishes there technically
okay well and the charts anasia also is
like
that so if you activate it now you can
see here that it
marks all the trading sessions okay and
this can help you to identify patterns
now if you think that this is too much
noise then you can remove these boxes
very quickly click okay and now it's
going a bit much easier you can even
remove the 50 if you want but I like to
have it to show the trend okay but yeah
uh it does the boxes for us so it's much
easier which I like so if any of you
like to use trading sessions then this
indicator also have that which I think
is very useful uh for example right
now today is not going to really play
out because if you know this Asia open
here in this area here and it Clos
pretty much in the same point and London
is well for that I would say that it's
been holding and it didn't go up just
holding and London is doing the same so
today I'm not going to have the trading
sessions pattern so I don't know what
New York is going to do based on this
okay so let me activate everything
again and remove the trading
sessions you see it's very fast to
enable things and off it loads fast
that's one of the things that I like the
most now also more things in settings
the wigs okay yes it marks the wigs that
need to get filled because you can see
here okay for example there is a we here
that needs to get filled this one too
but there are a few that have already
been filled for example this one here
this one here and if you notice the line
the yellow line is like fading and
that's because it's been filed well you
can change this okay you can change the
color of the field color you can even
reduce
opacity maybe in 5% so it's less noise
in the chart I like it better like this
in five
6% okay and yeah that's pretty much
everything about the settings now the
way that I use indicator is that for
example I can go to the fours time frame
and I can say okay we have a week here
to the
upsite let me see I'm going to use the
mouse maybe makes a bit of no sorry Bo
more much more easier for me so yes we
have for example a we to the to in this
area and we are above the 4our 50 ma
that if you notice it's been acting as
resistance all this time so here you can
see resistance resistance resistance
resistance and now perhaps it starts
acting as support so that is telling you
that if we have a we to the upside and
we are about the 4H hour 50 MAA perhaps
we test the 4H hour 50 May and that
helps us to go and fill this week okay
so that's for example a potential trade
that I'm seeing the 4 time frame now
this projection here I'll talk about
this projection again tomorrow but um I
think it makes sense because if you go
to the 8 hours time frame you can see
let me remove the dot you can see that
we also have a very long
week below it's huge okay it's like uh
let me check
6,200 it's a almost $2,000 week that's a
very long week and I'm marking there the
50% of the week as a potential retrace
also in the 8 hours time frame you can
see that we are testing the 50 ma as
resistance so um why not okay that's why
I like about the indicator that it
doesn't let me forget about anything
more about the liquidity pools one more
time frame so you can see here that if
well right now we are holding above the
50 ma but if we lose this
level then we're going to go lower to
fill this liquidity pool over here and
if we drop even lower below this area
here then they're going to go for the
next liquid pool okay so these are the
ways that you can use this chart now if
we go into a different um coin hang on
daily time frame you also have it
working there
okay there you go showing you liquidity
pools to the downside is showing you a
week to the upside and another week to
the downside okay this is the second
thing that is going to be worked in the
second version of the indicator and is
that if you notice this week here that
is marking is filling a previous week
right after so in theory I would like
that the second version wouldn't Mark me
this week that yes it's possible that we
fill it but according to my trading
system if a week is created to fill a
previous week then the chances to fill
this second week are lower than to fill
the first week so yes this first week it
was very lucky to get filled this second
week here that is marking now is less
likely than the first one so yes I think
uh I would like the second version to
not mark this week here okay but for
example in this case here this week is
not filling a previous week so this week
is very likely to get filled and it's a
70,000 okay and now let me take you to a
different asset let's go to an
altcoin for example Solana 4 hours time
frame so something interesting here that
I see is that well we have we have a
week to the downside un liquidity P to
the upsite so as long again look at this
50 Ma
strong resistance now it seems like a
strong support so as long as price
continues going up testing the 50 ma
then we'll Reach This liquidity pool
that's at 170 but however if we start to
drop here and we lose the the 50 ma then
it's likely that we go back to fill this
week down here at 125 so this is how the
way to use indicator now the way you
could use it is okay I'm going to wait
for another retrace of the 50ma see how
it reacts if it reacts holding then I
can open along here and I'm wishing for
price to go higher but my validation
will be to lose the 50 Ma and if we lose
it then I'm going to change to a short
position into this week okay that's an
example of how to use
indicator if you go into the one hour
time frame
well this is even more interesting so
listen to this because this is why
important we have a week here that's the
original week that's the second week
that basically is filling the previous
week but if you notice the 50% of this
week was around here and this is
something that I always tell you if we
fill the 50% of the week and then do you
see the do you see the reaction to the
downside the rejection perfect Bo
as long as you see price going back to
the 50% and consolidating around it then
it means that it's going to go up to the
100% of the week so yes it's very likely
that we end up today or tomorrow at this
level feeling the 100% of the week and
you can put this in any time frame so
that is why it's very useful the
indicator to Mark the week field
strategy okay because it can help you to
identify these kind of Trades so anyway
I think I show you
enough things of indicator I'm going to
be using it in the next videos of course
because I'm going to be using it every
day and now let's talk about how to
access the indicator so well I've
already mentioned that the ultimate goal
of the indicator is to go is to go live
to be public to be open for anybody in
trading view but for now we can't
because it's not perfect we have to
change a few things that I've even show
you in this video Bo you can you can
still access the these first versions
and for that you need to fit into one of
these two categories the first category
is to become a student of my course now
this applies to all time students and
giving access to even the students that
did the course one and a half years ago
and for that in the telegram channel of
the course you have a form you can fill
out the form ask you for your trading
view username and then I can give you
access so make sure to fill out a form
if you haven't already there are no new
courses uh for for sale because we just
started one yesterday the 1st of July
and the next one is going to be probably
in August but the website we are
basically remaking the website because
we're making it more functional we're
making it prettier and with more
functions so that's going to take
probably two or three weeks so for the
next two or three weeks you cannot buy
the course okay you have to wait and the
second category is to become an active
Trader using my referral link on B gex
that's the exchange that I been trading
for almost two years now I I really like
it so I'm happy there and for that we've
already selected 60 uids I'm going to
leave in the description so you can see
if you are one of them and these 60 uids
are going to receive an email this week
from BX with a new form again fill out a
form it's going to ask you for your
trading view username and then I can add
you to the indicator I can give you
access I love by the way that I'm
showing you this setup of Solana that is
going to go towards 100% of the week as
I speak but anyway the requirement that
we've set is 50,000 trading volume
within a time frame a period of 3 months
this is very easy because um it means
that in 3 months you have to at least
have done imagine 10 10 trades with
times 10 leverage of $500 so that's in
three months is quite lot you can even
divide that into a smaller trades um and
it'll take you to the same number but
yes I think that for three months uh 10
15 trades is very doable so many people
are going to get access this way the
access is also for three months so um at
the end of those three months of access
then I'm going to check again if you've
done the 50,000 trading volume if you've
reach that then I'll give you another
three months and so on and so on okay
and every month I'm adding new people so
yes H you have now until the 31st of
July to reach 50,000 trading uh dollars
worth of volume uh to give you access
but don't worry because if you don't do
it this month then your progress of this
month will count for the for also the
next two months okay so you have three
months period remember so I'm hoping
that many of you get access to this
version through this way to it took me a
while to think about ways to give you
access without making it public to
everybody because that would be a lot of
people and I want a lot people to get
access to it once it's perfect so for
now I'm only giving access to the cours
students because they have a lot of
knowledge and they are used to and they
had a lot of Education about this
trading system so they're going to be
able to give me very good feedback about
the weeks liquidity pool see how the
indicator works and also I'm giving
access to the referral link users
basically to to say thank you to them
because it's a direct way to support my
content so uh thank you very much you
have the link in the description of my
referral link and you're also going to
have there the list of the 60 uids that
are going to receive an email this week
and again if you are a course student
then make sure to fill out the form that
is in the channel so I can give you
access to it okay thank you very much
guys thank you for watching um
I bet you that Solana is going to get
here okay 100% of the week let's see in
the next couple of days so thank you so
much guys see you soon